how's it going everybody so we've been
treated a lot lately regarding
spider-man far from home we've had many
leaks over the past week and we saw what
appears to be spider-man stealth suit
and today we were treated with another
leaked video from the set of spider-man
far from home where we get an even
better look at the stealth suit reminder
about the giveaway I'm doing if you
would like to enter for your chance to
win a copy of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray some special edition posters and
some special memorabilia all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
so in this leaked video we get to see
the stealth suit in action so it starts
off with Spider Man on the floor it
seems like he just suffered some sort of
attack because there's debris everywhere
some of it is on fire and when he gets
up he looks around kind of assessing the
damage that is done to the surroundings
he then proceeds to shoot a few webs and
it's really hard to tell at what it
could possibly be based from this video
if I had to guess it's probably one of
two things one obviously a bad guy
it could be Mysterio molten man vulture
any one of the villains or two he could
be trying to hold some structures
together with some webs clearly there
was some sort of explosion and there's
damage done to wherever he's at it looks
like he's still at that ferris wheel and
this could be the more likely option
because right after he shoots a few webs
you can see him shoot a more
concentrated blast you can see that he
actually holds on to it this time and it
really does seem like he's trying to
keep something in place keep something
from falling down a structure could
possibly be about to fall on somebody so
he webs it and then he pulls it towards
him and then it looks like he braces for
impact looks like whatever he was
holding on to is now falling towards him
or if it is a villain and he actually
grabbed the villain with his web maybe
all of a sudden the villain turns and
starts attacking and that's what he's
bracing for whatever is going on here it
really seems like spider-man is
struggling
perhaps this stealth suit is just
something that he made maybe it's not a
suit that Tony Stark gave him but it's
much like the first suit that Peter
Parker made himself in homecoming and
it's just black he could have made this
to sneak around but then he got caught
in a battle and it doesn't have the same
capabilities as the other suits that
Stark made him so he's not as strong
this actually really resembles the
spider-man Newar suit spider-man you are
it was a series that was an alternate
universe spider-man and he made the suit
himself and the only thing that was why
it was the eyes much like we see in this
video the suit also premiered in the
latest spider-man ps4 game so perhaps
there's some sort of connection there
whatever it may be
it looks like spider-man's gonna have
his work cut out for him and spider-man
far from home so what do you all think
about this video the new suit and who do
you think attacked him let me know your
thoughts in the comments below
again all you have to do to enter the
giveaway is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero
thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]